so we're told Circle P is below this is
circle P right over here what is the arc
measure of Arc BC in degrees so this is
point B this is Point C let me pick a
different color so you can see the arc
and since they only gave us two letters
we really want to find the minor arc so
we want to find the shorter arc between
B and C so the major arc would be the
long way around and if they wanted to
specify the major arc they would have
had to give us three letters to force us
to go the long way around so B if they
said arc BAC or B DC that would go the
long way around but since they just gave
us just B and C we assume it's going to
be the minor arc so we want to find that
arc measure right over there now the arc
measure is going to be the exact same
measure in degrees as the measure of the
angle that the central angle that
intercepts that arc so it's going to be
the same thing as the measure of this
central angle which is 4 K plus 159
degrees so we can figure out what K is
we're going to know what this central
angle measure is and then that's going
to be the same thing as this arc measure
so how do we figure that out well what
might jump out at you is that this angle
angle BP C that we care about is
vertical to angle APD these are vertical
angles and so and vertical angles are
going to have the same measure they're
going to have there they are they are
they're going to be congruent so let's
set these two measures equal to each
other so we know that for K plus 159 is
going to be equal to 2k plus 153 so
let's get all of our K terms on the
left-hand side and all of the all of the
non K terms on the right-hand side so
let's subtract 2k from both sides so we
can subtract 2k from both sides and
let's subtract well let me just do that
first I don't want to skip steps and so
I got rid of the K's on the right hand
side so it's just going to have be left
with the 153 and on the left-hand side
for K minus 2 K is 2k and I still have
plus 159 now let's get rid of this 159
on the left
and side so let's subtract it but if I
do it on the left hand side I need to do
it on the right hand side as well so
subtract 159 from both sides and I'm
left with 2 K is equal to 153 minus 159
is negative 6 so K is equal to just
divide both sides by 2 K is going to be
equal to negative 3 now you might be
tempted to say Oh negative 3 but that's
not where we're trying we're not just
trying to solve for K we're trying to
figure out this angle measure which is
going to be the same as the arc measure
that we care about and that's just
expressed in terms of K so it's 4 times
K + 159 so that's going to be 4 times
negative 3 plus 159 well what's that
going to be 4 times negative 3 is
negative 12 plus 159 is going to be 147
so the this angle right here has a
measure of 147 degrees and you can
calculate that's the same thing as over
here knit 2 times negative 3 is negative
6 plus 153 is 147 degrees these two are
the same and so 147 degrees this angle
measure is the same as the measure of
Arc BC let's do one more of these circle
P is below what is the arc measure of
b/c in degrees now since it once again
they only gave us two letters we can
assume it as the minor arc so we care
about we care about BC we care about
this right over here and what so what is
the measure of this arc is going to be
the same thing as the measure of the
central angle that intercepts that arc
and that measure is going to be the sum
of these two angles so it's going to be
so it's going to be 4y plus 6 plus 7 y
minus 7 so what's that 4y plus 7y the Y
we can combine the Y terms is going to
be 11 y and then 6 minus 7 is going to
be negative 1 so it's going to be 11 Y
minus 1 and how do we figure that out
how do we figure out what Y is we need
to figure out why is in order
what 11 y -1 is well we know let me
write this down so the angle that we
care about is 11 y -1 11 y -1 we know
that that angle plus this big angle that
I'm going to show in blue then if we add
them together that it's going to be 360
degrees because we would have gone all
the way around the circle so we know
that 11 y -1 plus 20 Y minus 11 is going
to be equal to 360 degrees and so now we
can just solve for y what is let me get
some new colors involved what is 11 y
plus 20y well that's going to be 31 Y
and then if I have negative 1 and
negative 11 that's going to be negative
let me do this in a different color so
that's going to be that's going to be
negative 1 negative 11 that's negative
12 and that's going to be equal to 360
degrees 360 so let's see we could add 12
to both sides to get rid of that
negative 12 right over there and that's
going to leave us with 31 y is equal to
372 and so if we divide both sides by 31
it looks like 12 yep it'll go exactly 12
times so Y is equal to 12 which is equal
to 12 and remember we weren't trying to
solve for y we were trying to solve for
xi y minus 1 so what is 11 times 12 we
know that Y is 12 11 times 12 minus 1z
11 times 12 is 102 120 21 and then 121
minus 1 is going to be all right now
it's going to sex discredit via and my
multiplication tables are off it's it's
been a long day 11 times 12 is going to
be a hundred and
and 132 132 minus 1 is going to be 131
and it's going to be in degrees so 131
degrees that's the measure of this angle
which is going to be the measure of
minor arc BC